their revision politic we love talking
about Asia and you probably know that by
now and we like it because there are
certain things that this region has that
can contribute a lot to the improvement
of our world however not everything is
as good as it sounds in Asia well we can
certainly see plenty of lights there are
also lots of shadows and the largest
shadow is that without any doubt the
area has become a huge powder keg ready
to blow on the one hand the area is
spending more and more in weapons in
fact it is expected that by 2020 the
region will account for more than 30
percent of all of the world's military
spending and on top of that it's also
becoming a chess board for geopolitics
China and India are big emerging powers
and with time they are demanding a
larger and larger international
influence Putin's Russia has started to
feel concerned by the Pacific and well
so is the United States meaning this
area is extremely important now from the
other hands there are many disagreements
between the different countries in this
region and it seems that lately they
have been looking for any reason to
start a fight we can find all kinds of
conflicts here Beck anomic territorial
historical I mean China's conflict with
Vietnam here with Japan over there and
then there is India the situation with
Taiwan and the problems between Japan
and Russia and that's not even
considering the situation in Korea I
mean the list just grows longer and
longer we have talked about many of
these but today we're going to focus on
the sleeping giants and that's Japan
the two nightmares of Japan Japan is the
world's largest economy but despite that
this country has a modest role in
international politics and it's been
that way for the last few decades
however the situation is changing
particularly for two reasons
China and North Korea first there is the
emergence of China as a superpower but
why does Japan care about that well
basically because the emergence of China
has led to setbacks in Japan's regional
influence so that both countries
maintain a bitter conflicts over a small
archipelago known as the Senkaku Islands
the Senkaku Islands are abandoned but
there's still a key area in the fishing
industry they calls large deposits of
petrol and gas and there are also
strategic in sea trade well just take a
look at this chart to see how the
military budget of both countries has
evolved in the last few years or giving
you a better understanding of Japan's
concern about China's emergence
[Music]
certain and more recently there is North
Korea t only idea viewer has been
obsessed for the last 20 years amounts
of vetting unconventional war capacities
please and mainly being its nuclear
capability for now North Korea is
managed to create an atomic bomb of
certain Keela tons of switches
comparable do twice the bomb that was
used on Hiroshima
they've also succeeded in making
ballistic missiles which can reach not
only South Korea but also Japan in March
2017 North Korea launched four ballistic
missiles in Japan's direction it was
successful and three out of four of them
reached Japanese territorial waters less
than 200 miles from the Japanese coast
well all of this is producing a real
psychosis in Japan the Japanese
government itself has started to conduct
evacuation drills in the event of a
hypothetical attack and has even
distributed a detailed guide to explain
how Japanese citizens should respond to
a North Korean nuclear attack Tokyo says
that people should have about ten
minutes to react person that might be an
overestimation a missile may not be
detected as soon as it leaves launch pad
pending on the case the warnings and
alarms might only sound for five minutes
before a missile arrives with all of
this going on we shouldn't be surprised
to find out that Japan is acquiring many
nuclear shelters as well as equipment
for purifying the air which are designed
to fight radiation as well as poisonous
gas into obby the Japanese Prime
Minister has confirmed North Korea also
has the ability to launch sarin gas
missiles so ignoring whether the North
Korean threat is real or not the reality
is that China and North Korea are
perceived as being significant threats
by Tokyo but before explaining how the
country is planning to fight these
threats let's have a look at what has
been the foundation of their defence
policy in the last few decades
Japan a part of this country as you all
know Japan was one of the countries that
lost world war two as a consequence of
this defeat the country had to establish
a constitution in 1947 and that
Constitution is still in force today in
this constitution
it states that war and the use of force
is not to be used unless in self-defense
aspiring sincerely to an international
peace based on justice and order the
Japanese people forever renounce war as
a sovereign right of the nation in order
to accomplish the aim of the preceding
paragraph land sea and air forces as
well as other world potential will never
be maintained article 9 of the Japanese
Constitution this means that at first
the idea was that Japan couldn't even
have an army the country's protection
was the responsibility of the US however
the Korean War and the tension suffered
during the years of the Cold War
changed everything all of a sudden both
Tokyo as well as Washington understood
it was essential to form a support force
for the American army in case Japan
needed defense and that is how the
Japanese self-defense forces were born
this is an army whose only possible
purpose is defense but one thing is true
formally the u.s. still takes care of
Japan's protection and keeps more than
40,000 soldiers deployed in the country
and also maintains some of its largest
military bases in Japan this is a fourth
by the way that is co-financed by the
government in Japan itself we could even
say that Japan is the largest spearhead
of the u.s. in Asia however the new
threats Japan perceives in the region
from China and North Korea of course
Japan's are no longer be satisfied with
this protection so the big question is
how is Japan responding to these threats
[Music]
are these new diplomacy to begin with
the japanese prime minister shinzo are
they has started an unusual diplomatic
race to work against the growing
influence of China for now he has
managed to improve the country's
relations with South Korea and to
strengthen its bonds with the US and
even bridge the gap existing with
Pinkins Russia Japan maintains an
intense dispute over the sovereignty of
a small archipelago known as the Kuril
Islands which Russia claims is now under
their sovereignty in fact the diplomacy
our day has started is so intense that
the country is now competing with China
in Africa Japan and China compete for
African markets I'm the curious fact
Shinzo are.they was also the first
international leader to meet with Trump
in the famous residence the American
President owns in Florida it seems like
after this encounter are they managed to
win over the presidents and make him
forget all the attacks made against
Japan when he was still a candidate for
the presidency because one thing is true
from complained quite a lot about Japan
but you know things can change we are
committed to the security of Japan and
all areas under its administrative
control the friendship between our two
peoples runs a very very deep but of
course diplomacy is not always enough
[Music]
Japan's free army and so finally we
reach the key point the Japanese
self-defense forces are often thought of
as some sort of small band of men but
really nothing is further from the truth
the Japanese army is larger than the
army of France and the UK combined now
it is true that given their name you may
not think that they are important but
the abilities and capacity of this
strange army is impressive for many
analysts they are still the best army in
all of Asia although China certainly
competes for that top spot and look
Japan's investment in defense is quite
low at less than 1% of its GDP but that
is still a lot of money take a look at
this in 2016
Japan was the country with the seventh
highest spending on defense in 2017 the
government will give the forces the
largest budget in its history more than
five trillion yen which is around forty
five billion dollars and of course such
a quantity and such a small and by the
way very well-trained army is enough for
them to acquire some of the most modern
systems available for example there's
the f-35 the best American drones via
Zhu mu path aircraft carriers or even
being used fifth-generation fighter jets
which mr. bushy is developing Japan
reveals the prototype at the splashed
furtive fighters the thing is that since
our they became prime minister in 2012
he has had the clear idea of leaving
behind the pacifist character sent by
the Japanese Constitution and this has
happened in 2014 the Chinese government
decided to stop all restrictions on the
export of warfare material with the goal
of starting a new Japanese military
industry and that later in 2015 are they
also led a reform says that the
self-defense forces could operate abroad
and today they even have a military base
in Djibouti
and of course the military budget has
increased again after many years of
budget cuts but not only this they are
even thinking about changing the
constitution the radical military shift
of Japan echoes the ghosts of World War
2 so now comes the point in the video
where we ask what you think do you think
Japan should leave its pacifism aside
should Japan give in to Beijing which
country seems like a better Ally for you
Japan or China well please leave your
answers in the comments below and do
click like if you enjoyed this video
also don't forget to check out our
friends at reconsider Mediacom the
podcast where you can hear the voice of
this video that is in mind and don't
forget to subscribe to read new videos
every Monday and Thursday and as always
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you